Candid Truth. What is up? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it yesterday. Trump
just said that he was going to build a
golden dome over America and he might
include Canada. He said he's talking to
them. This is crazy. What in the world
does that even look like? A golden dome?
Why are we doing this? There's a lot of
esoteric language in these speeches that
he's making and we're going to get into
all that. But this has been programmed
predictively, predictive programming
through the Simpsons. You know, there's
a lot of uh connections out there like
this right here. We know that Lisa was
wearing the exact same outfit as Kamala
back in 2020 and then she was running
for in 2024 and all this stuff. And a
big pet peeve of mine is when I see
these AI generated Simpsons things and
and they're being passed around as
saying, "Look, look, the Simpsons
predicted the future." Or they take an
episode that came out after the event
and they put a date on there that makes
it look like it came out before the
event and says that The Simpsons
predicted it. That's all garbage. If you
ever see Homer Simpson with two pupils
or Bart Simpson with four arms, you know
it's AI generated. Stop passing this
garbage around as legitimacy in the
truther community. You're giving us a
bad name. But Matt Grooning, the creator
of the Simpsons, is a 33 degree
Freemason. Where is he getting his
inspiration from from? I believe he's
getting it from Satan himself. And Satan
has a plan. The Bible says that we do
not wrestle against flesh and blood, but
against principalities, against the
rulers of the darkness of this age, this
world. That means that the rulers of
this world are literally working for
Satan. The Bible says that Satan is the
god of this world who is blinding the
minds. That he's going to deceive the
entire world. The dragon is going to
deceive the entire world and the whole
world will be deceived by sorcery which
which in the Greek is pharmarmacia.
Anything that medicates the mind, media,
drugs, pharmaceuticals, all that stuff,
we're seeing it today. predictive
programming. It's Satan's prophecies
basically. But I'm going to show you an
example from the Simpsons. For one, this
was on the news on the Simpsons where a
dome covered all of Springfield. And now
our news is showing the exact same
thing. It's mindblowing. Check out the
clip.
remain sealed in a doom.
Trapped forever. It's all come true.
That crazy old man in church was right.
It This is from the movie. In the movie,
Grandpa Simpson was at church laying on
the floor rolling around and saying
something that sounded like tongues. He
was saying, "Ea, ea, uh, trapped
forever." And they're like, "What does
this mean?" And they found out right
here that when the EPA delivered the
dome and and trapped all of Springfield,
that that's what he was talking about.
But the Simpsons is always attacking
God, always talk attacking Christianity,
the Bible, all that stuff. And I just
think it's interesting that they're
like, "That crazy old man was right.
That crazy old man in church was right."
When it is us, we are the ones with the
truth. The Christians who read the
Bible, understand prophecy, we have had
the truth all along. The sad part is is
that so much of the church is asleep
today. And used to you'd see a Christian
on the side of the road holding up a
sign saying, "The end is near." And now
Christians are asleep. And they're
playing around in the world. one foot in
the world, one foot in the church, and
they're lukewarm. And when Christ
returns, he's going to say, "Depart from
me. I never knew you, you workers of
iniquity." Even though these people are
saying, "Lord, Lord," they're calling
him Lord. He's saying, "I never knew
you. You didn't have a real relationship
with me because if you did, you would
have fruit." Jesus said, "You'll know
them by their fruits, not because they
hold a Bible and wear a cross and go to
church every week, but because they live
according to his commands." And what are
his commandments? Everything he says.
says we need to live according to the
way he walked. This clip goes on to say
who actually trapped them in the dome.
What ruthless madman could have done
this to us? The United States
government.
[Music]
The United States government. I mean, so
in the movie they're saying that the
United States government is going to put
a dome over a large portion of the
world, which in this uh movie was
Springfield. But now we are seeing Trump
echo some of these things. This is
crazy. Listen to what Trump says in this
speech and and listen for these um these
esoteric terms like golden because he's
gonna bring in the golden age, right? We
know that that's the new age, the age of
Aquarius, when everyone slips into
Christ consciousness and we're all on
the same plane with spirit realm and all
this stuff. He's been talking about
this, saying that we're in the golden
age. Now he's talking about a golden
dome. And he's talking about architects,
the grand architect, the Freemasons,
when they have that G and the in the uh
compass and square, that's the great
architect, the grand architect. So he he
mentions the Golden Dome, the architect,
and some other things. Just check this
out. I promised the American people that
I would build a cutting edge missile
defense shield to protect our homeland
from the threat of foreign missile
attack. We have officially selected an
architecture for the state-of-the-art
system that will deploy next generation
technologies. This design for the Golden
Dome will in integrate with our existing
defense capabilities and should be fully
operational before the end of my term.
So, we'll have it done in about 3 years.
Once fully constructed, the Golden Dome
will be capable of intercepting missiles
even if they are launched from other
sides of the world and even if they're
launched from space.
Okay. So, he he says that there's going
to be a golden dome. I don't think this
is going to be a physical dome. That's
kind of impossible. But there's some
kind of electronic technological dome
that's going to protect us from missiles
from other countries and even attacks
from outer space. Attacks from outer
space. Why are we trying to protect
ourselves from a threat from an empty
void out there? Why have they been
telling us for years now that aliens are
real? That UFOs are real? We're having
UFO We're having US congressional
hearings where the military is is saying
UFOs are real and we talk to nonhuman
intelligences and have been since the
1930s. They're not even calling them
alien. They're saying nonhuman
intelligences and telling us that
they're interdimensional. So, we're
having US congressional hearings where
the military is saying we communicate
with
interdimensional intelligences.
Tell me you're speaking to non tell me
you're speaking to demons without
telling me you're talking to demons.
That's what they're doing. And all of
this is Bible prophecy. I'm going to get
into that. But notice he said an
architect. The architecture which we're
we're talking about something like
that's not even physical. Not not a
physical dome. So architecture seems
like a strange word to use. The golden
dome protecting us from threats from
outside.
Well, this isn't really new because when
Trump was in in his first term, he
introduced the US Space Force. Why?
Because the militaries of the world are
preparing for a battle. A battle from a
threat that's coming from out there to
Earth. Is this is this anything clicking
right now? This was years ago. I don't
even remember the years, but the first
time he was in, he unrolled the US Space
Force. This must have been 2020 because
during COVID there was this huge
5,000page document that in there it said
we demand to know everything you know
about UFOs. What does that have to do
with COVID? I have no idea. But they
said that there were double the amount
of sightings since the pandemic. This
was all in the news. They said since the
pandemic, people have seen double the
amount of sightings. And then in this
huge document, we demand to know
everything you know about UFOs. Oh, by
the way, months later, we're going to
roll out the US Space Force. We're going
to protect Earth from a threat from out
there. We're going to build a dome that
protects us from a threat out there. In
the scriptures, it says, "I saw three
unclean spirits like frogs." You think
about, just think about sci-fi and think
about what looks like a frog. These
alien grays look like frogs, right? I
saw three unclean spirits like frogs
come out of the mouth of the dragon, the
mouth of the these are the the mouths of
the kingdoms of the earth, for they are
the spirits of devils. So these froglike
beings are the spirits of devils, and
they're working miracles, flying around
in crafts that defy physics, right?
Which go forth unto the kings of the
earth, the kings of the earth would be
Trump and everyone else, right? the
elites of the world and of the whole
world and gather them to the battle of
the great day of God Almighty. So the
Bible's literally telling us and we're
seeing it happen right before our very
eyes that three unclean spirits like
frogs are going to unite the militaries
of the world to fight against the second
coming of Christ. We're seeing it right
here. What is predictive programming?
While the term predictive programming
primarily is associated with conspiracy
theories and occult interpretation could
potentially link it to esoteric concepts
of shaping reality through ritual and
symbolic manipulation according to the
interesting engineering. So this is AI's
answer from Google. It's scouring the
internet looking for the best answer.
And it's saying that in the occult
circle, predictive programming could be
a symbolic ritual that's going to bring
things into manifestation. So check this
out. Point one says, "Reality shaping
through ritual and symbolism. Some
occult traditions emphasize the power of
ritual, symbolism, and focused intention
to influence the material world." So
this is the the same concept as as the
law of attraction. We did a video on law
of attraction. Check that out. It's so
close to the truth because the Bible
says, "Whatever so things you ask for in
my name, it will be given unto you."
That the power of life and death is in
the tongue, right? But this is the law
of attraction is a counterfeit of the
truth. And so when poor people look in
the mirror and they say, "I'm rich. I'm
a millionaire." And all these things and
you're not asking God for those things,
which those things don't always are the
best things for you because Jesus said,
"It's hard for a rich man to enter the
kingdom of heaven, right? We have to ask
according to his will. But when these
people go from rags to riches and they
tell you, you know what, I just I just
believed. I just prayed to the universe
and the universe just blessed me with
these things. Right? That's Satan. When
you are praying to something else other
than God, Satan is going to come in and
answer that prayer. Why? Because now you
have fallen for the deception. You can
say, "I literally had my life changed by
this law of attraction." Now you're sold
out for Satan and you become an
evangelist for Satan when you start
telling everyone else and you start
writing books like the secret and this
is a huge book that so many people are
are uh reading and believing in this
framework. Predictive programming
particularly when embedded in media
might be seen as a large scale albeit
unconscious or semiconscious ritual
designed to imprint certain realities
into the collective psyche. So you got
millions of people watching the same
prophecy. Satan's counterfeit of
prophecy is predictive programming. So
how does God speak to humanity? Through
his word, his book. And he has
prophecies that are 100% true and they
will come true and they are coming true.
And so Satan loves to pervert and
counterfeit everything God does. So he
says, "You know what? I have an agenda,
too. And I have a future that I want to
make happen. And so I'm gonna tell my
prophecies through predictive
programming. And more people are
watching his predictive programming than
reading the prophecies. And that even
includes the Christian church. That's
sad to say and it's the truth. And so
we're all being fed this stuff. Number
two, subliminal influencing and the
collective unconscious. Occult practices
often involve working with the
subconscious mind and the collective
unconscious. sometimes through
techniques like sigil magic or
visualization. So if you ever wonder why
do they always put an all-seeing eye?
Why do they always put a pentagram
hidden hidden in the background of some
movie? This is sigil magic. These elites
of the world are trying to cast spells
on you. That's why it's called casting.
It's broadcast, right? We're gonna
Hollywood is the witch's wand made of
holly that lulls humanity to sleep as
it's
broadcasting its spell over humanity.
Predictive programming could be
interpreted as a form of subliminal
messaging, aiming to bypass conscious
awareness and directly influence beliefs
and
expectations at a deeper level,
potentially tapping into the collective
unconscious. So, we're unconsciously
getting these messages all the time.
911, 911, UFOs, UFOs, over and over and
over, and it's desensitizing us to where
when it happens, we're almost expecting
it. But Satan has been telling us his
plan the whole time through his
disciples, which are movie writers and
singers and actors and all this stuff.
Number three, esoteric interpretation of
prophecy and foresight. Some occult
systems acknowledge the potential for
individuals or groups to possess
foresight or the ability to perceive
future possibilities through various
means. This is what I'm talking about.
These people who write the scripts, who
act the roles, they are telling you
openly that's not me out there. I could
have never acted that part. Something
else came inside me and I nailed the
part. They will tell you that. Even
Denzel Washington, Lucil Ball, all these
people. And then the screenwriters say,
"You know what? I I had a dream." The
lady that wrote Harry Potter had a
dream, wrote it on a napkin, and now
it's like one of the number three
bestselling books of all time. Uh the
James Cameron, number one selling movie
of all time, Avatar, was given to him in
a dream. Terminator in a dream. So these
people are getting their inspiration
from somewhere else, and they're
admitting it. I 100% believe that Satan
is inspiring these people. When I go
speak somewhere, I'm asking God, fill me
with your Holy Spirit. Give me your
words, not mine. And I'm praying, asking
God to speak through me. These people
are not doing that. These people are
living lifestyles of alcohol and drugs
and uh immorality. And they're not
praying to God for any kind of
protection or help. And so, they're
getting their inspiration from somewhere
else. I believe that we are inspired by
one side or the other. And it it all
depends on which way are you walking
because Jesus said, "If you're not with
me, you are against me." It's black and
white just like that. This stuff has
been prophesied in the esoteric world
for so long that even Alice Bailey and
Bllovzky and all these people were
talking about the year 2025 was going to
be a big year. Alice Bailey wrote the
about the externalization of the
hierarchy would happen in the year 2025.
And what that is is a manifestation of
the spirit world, the age of Aquarius.
She wrote it all in this book. And it's
on Lucius Trust, which used to be called
Lucifer Trust, but that was too
obviously wicked. So they changed the
name of this organization. But this
organization, Lucius Trust, has been
adopted by the United Nations. Why are
they taking the writings of some
esoteric channeler? because the world is
controlled by Satan himself and by those
who serve him. Even the Bush family uh
believed in astrology and often call up
mediums and psychics to to know what we
should do next. What's our next game
plan? This is what the Bible says.
Satan's the god of this world. In the
Christian world, Christians are
predicting that in the year
2030, Jesus is going to come back.
Right? I I've seen that a whole bunch of
these channels. There's even a whole
documentary called Messiah 2030. I'm not
setting dates. I don't believe that
there's a certain date that I can know
that Jesus is coming back. But I know
he's coming soon. Satan knows Jesus is
coming soon. The occultists know that
Jesus is coming soon, that they're
Christ, that their Messiah is coming
soon. That means that Satan is ready to
come on the scenes as a supernatural
being, an angel of light, a messiah, and
the stage is being set for the whole
entire world to embrace him as Christ.
Because these people, they play the
Hegelian dialectic. They It's a swinging
pendulum. They go far left. Far right is
order out of chaos. We had the far right
where there's 86 genders and cut off the
genitals off your children and and all
this chaos and then Trump comes in and
people think, "Oh, he's the messiah.
He's going to save the day because he's
bringing normaly back. Bringing back
normaly doesn't change the agenda." This
is a two steps forward, one step back.
So the agenda for new world order is
still being played out. So while you're
putting your trust in some man that's
bringing back normaly because he's
saying, "You know what? We should get
rid of artificial colors and poison in
our food and stop spraying the skies and
all this stuff which is normal. We're
bringing normal back. The agenda is
still being unrolled. Never put your
trust in a man. Put your trust in Christ
alone. No man is going to save the day.
This agenda is going to roll out no
matter who's in office. Trump is a an
elite puppet. He's no different than any
of the rest. And I hope that the things
that we talk about prove that to you
without a shadow of a doubt. They call
us homeland terrorists if we prep or
have a garden or homeschool or can
things or whatever. They call us
preppers and conspiracy theorists and
all this stuff. But the military are the
biggest preppers of all time. They have
deep underground militarybased systems
thousands of feet underground with
two-way byways for semi-truckss to go
both ways and make deliveries. And
they're growing rice underground. And
they're building a dome over America to
protect us from some kind of threat out
there. And we have a space force to
protect us from some threat that's out
there. According to the
Bible, there's nothing out there but
water. It says that there's a firmament
that divides the waters above from the
waters below. We prove that this whole
space agency stuff is fake. go to our
videos tab and check out the video that
has the thumbnail of one of the
astronauts throwing up the 666 over his
eyes. It's like 20some minutes long and
100% proves that these people are liars.
Even the name NASA is the Hebrew word
for deceive and beguile. Do not put your
trust in men. These people are preparing
for Christ to come. We need to be ready.
The Bible says, "Be ready because Christ
is coming soon." We don't have time to
be playing around with sin. One foot in
the world, one foot in the church, and
the grass is greener over there. Satan
knows his time is short. And like an
angry dragon, he is angry with the woman
who keep the commandments of God and
have the faith and testimony of Jesus
Christ. We must be fully surrendered to
Christ every single day, picking up our
cross daily, walking with him, asking
for the Holy Spirit to indwell in us,
asking God, fill us with your Holy
Spirit. Give me victory over this
challenge in my life, over this
temptation in my life. And we need to be
walking with Christ every day. Jesus
told a parable about the 10 virgins.
Virgins represent Christians. And they
all had lamps with oil in their lamps,
which represents the Holy Spirit. So, in
this parable, there are 10 Holy
Spiritfilled Christians, and they all
fell asleep before the wedding, the
wedding that we're supposed to have with
Jesus Christ. But five of them woke up
and proceeded to the wedding. And the
other five woke up and said, "Hey, can
we have some of your oil?" And they
said, "If we give you some of our oil,
we won't have enough to make it to the
wedding. Go buy some more yourself." And
when they went to go buy some more, they
ran out of time. We cannot be those five
foolish virgins that didn't make it. We
must be filling ourselves with God's
word, filling our minds with his
scriptures, being filled with prayer,
asking God, help us through this. Help
me with this thing. Get help me to get
rid of this thing in my life. Help me to
walk according to your will every single
day. Satan knows Jesus is coming soon.
Do you? We need to be ready. If you guys
are blessed by this video, please give
it a thumbs up. It really helps this
video get out out into the algorithm. If
you're new to this channel, please click
subscribe. We got a lot of cool content.
We have been talking about this stuff
for a long time. CERN and conspiracy
theories and the new pope and um
predictive programming. If you are
interested in this stuff, please check
out our channel. We also now officially
have a Patreon by popular request. So
many people asked us to get a Patreon
because we only had digital forms of
giving before that. And Patreon just
makes it so much easier. You just sign
up. It comes right out of your bank
every month and it really helps us
because we want to expand Candid Truth.
We want Candid Truth on Tik Tok. We want
Candid Truth on Bitshoot and Rumble and
Instagram and all these places that we
don't have time to make reels and shorts
and all these things. But there's a
world of people out there that need to
hear these messages as well. With your
help, we can hire another person on the
team to do these things for us to take
care of social media and all that stuff.
And we can keep cranking out content
like this. so that you guys can be
informed of what's going on. If you want
to give other ways, go to cantruth.org.
We got other different digital ways to
give. If you like t-shirts, we got cool
t-shirts and we make about $5 a pop on
these shirts and it really, really
helps. We love you guys. We thank you
guys. We cannot do this without you.
We'll see you next time on Candid Truth.